你老公这经济上这个事儿的话，
基本上可以说是常态，
因为现实生活中，
如果说挣钱多的那个人是不可能一笔一笔的，
所有的账都给挣钱少的那个人去汇报清楚的，
这是实话，
33岁，
结婚7年，
有两个孩子，
一儿一女，
我在体制内呢，
工作做到了中途偏上吧，
由于种种原因吧，
短时间内也不可能再当一把手，
所以说我这个在工作内的心态应该是属于一种半躺型的心态，
正常我的年收入大概是8万左右吧，
但是工作单位离家有点远，
通城区也就六七十公里，
每天通勤，
在我们这个小城市来说，
就是属于那种通勤时间比较长，
比较辛苦的类型，
但是孩子就还比较小，
我老公呢是比我大四岁，
他的工作性质呢是全国各地出差，
但是我跟他是相亲认识，
他是体制内国企工作，
因为收入等等的原因，
我也支持他去做技术，
他就辞职到外面去工作，
现在的年收入差不多30~40左右，
不是技术类工作。
我觉得我们两个一直以来的问题其实就是在于金钱的问题，
他父母没有在他身边，
以至于说他从小一些决定是自己做，
特别独立。
我在结婚刚开始就发现，
就是说他好像一些事情他不愿意跟我说，
参给我老公，
因为整体评价人非常的上进，
也踏实，
也刻苦，
也努力，
对自己的生活呢欲望也不是很高，
他会说今年这几件衣服够穿，
那我就不买，
不会说我换季我就要买衣服。
也没有不良嗜好，
但是呢，
他自己非常有主意，
比如说他这个事情他认为该这么做，
那他就觉得任何人可能都改变不了他的想法，
因为我老公的工作性质嘛，
再加上我工作也比较忙，
我婆婆是跟我住在一起，
接送老大，
照顾老二，
因为我们老二的年纪还比较小，
一岁多，
我婆婆把我家庭照顾屁，
我料理的很好，
也减轻了我的负担。
我先说我跟我老公的几个矛盾点吧，
这件事情在我心当中过去了，
但是我就想跟您说说话，
第一个点呢，
我在婚后发现他借给他同学钱，
当时其实我们两个刚结婚，
他手里是没有什么钱的，
所以他没钱借给他，
他用他自己的个人名义去找他的同学借给他朋友钱，
当然也不错过金额是多少啊，
他好像就是三四万的样子的，
同学是着急买车还是还是怎么样子，
但是后来三四个月之内这个钱也还上了，
但是我就觉得你这么大的事情，
我也已经跟你结婚，
你为什么不跟我说，
这是第一个小矛盾，
第二个矛盾，
我婚后就发现她在给我婆婆打钱，
她的理由是因为我婆婆在老家庭付出很多，
也没有退休金，
没有办法出去挣钱，
而且我们结婚买房已经花了他的很多积蓄，
所以要给钱，
这个点呢，
我也没有再继续纠缠，
因为我觉得这也是应该的嘛，
我们结婚的时候，
她答案是每年1500，
每年涨500块钱，
现在应该涨到3500，
但是这个过程当中我都没有再纠结这个事情，
因为我婆婆的付出确实是付出很多，
但是我纠结的事情是，
她所有问题都是先斩后做。
都是他做，
我发现了，
他才会跟我说。
第三个问题就是二三年的时候，
我偶然之间发现他签的公司是北京公司，
但是他从来没有发过年终奖，
他刚开始跟我说的理由是他工作不满一年怎么之类的，
我说那这肯定不正常，
他就跟我说他实际上我们在结婚，
买这个婚房，
家里欠了20万，
但是为什么没有跟我说，
是因为怕我承受不住，
因为我当时婚前的条件是在本地有车有房有编制，
在他的本心一个预设认为我是没有经历过什么大风大浪的，
他说跟你说欠了20万，
你肯定会承受不住，
这个事情我自己独自消化了几天吧，
我也过去了。
第4个事情就他有陆续借给家人钱，
因为这两年他亲戚朋友过得不怎么样，
也应该在5万以内吧，
我也没有在纠结这件事情，
去年的11月份儿，
他工作性在是在外地工作，
两到三周回来一次，
回来两天，
我们的夫妻生活也很正常，
我偶然之间发现他按摩这件事情，
我觉得是我特别不能容忍的，
他就说没有发生过分的，
而且就说有时候是喝了酒跟别人一起去怎么样，
我说这个我不能容忍，
这件事情我们纠缠了两三天，
我也让双方父母都知道了，
而且也签了婚内财产约定书，
后来我觉得如果说一直在纠结这个事情，
对我们两个之间的关系也没有什么好处，
所以我就说这件事情也翻篇，
但是就跟他说，
我说这件事情我不能不。
然后行，
以后就绝对不会再发生这样的事情，
接下来发生的事情就是今天晚上的事情，
发现他按摩一天之后，
我们就说就是所有的工资你就要给我打嘛，
后来我就发现他因为出差的这种工作性质，
实际上我是管不了他钱的，
因为有一些需要垫资啊，
报销流程之类的也不现实，
我也不希望我们的夫妻关系过于紧张，
所以呢，
我就说那你就年终奖发个大头，
10~20那个样子的，
我就一次性打给我就好了，
我是知道他有一笔钱，
当时公司没有打给他了，
我今天呢，
就偶尔还问起来，
她说已经给她了，
但是她就给了，
我婆婆说多不多，
说少不少，
5万块钱吧。
我说为什么没有给我，
因为我上周刚好去做一个手术，
她说因为你去做手术了，
我没有跟你说，
我说不是说好的给我吗？
他说那给了妈姨妈也是存住，
他不乱花怎么之类的，
但是我心里面这个事儿，
就觉得我们一直以来这些矛盾，
这些问题都是因为钱上面，
他从来不说，
他从来都是说自己做了，
我问起来他跟我讲，
我觉得心里面有一点点不舒服，
所以想找你来倾诉一下，
首先大概说了几句话，
一，
他没有数，
因为他的工作性质是课程，
是跑，
而且我们之间的发微信视频都是随时可以把可发的，
第2点呢，
我婆婆确实为我们小家庭付出很多，
也很吃苦耐劳的帮我带孩子，
但是在我们这个夫妻关系上面，
我觉得没有形成什么正面的影响。
比如说我们俩个一。
下他都会帮助他儿子就说那就去离婚，
不是怎么怎么样，
相处了这么久，
心里也是有点寒心的，
我问一个问题啊，
平时因为你要上班，
你老公也要上班，
婆婆在家带孩子，
是不是在家做饭呀，
做菜呀，
买菜呀，
很多这种零零碎碎的孩子的零食开销啊，
也是婆婆承担的呢？
我婆婆是承担买菜钱比较多，
她自己的衣服，
比如说她自己想买个花啊，
买点药呀，
是他自己承担，
像孩子的零食、
奶粉、
保育费，
衣服都是我来家里的水果谁买呢？
家里的水果我想到了我就买，
或者她觉得缺少什么他也买，
那你不觉得一个月给婆婆那3000多块钱，
实际上都被你们吃掉了吗？
你不当家，
不吃柴米贵，
你知道现在出去买肉买菜，
你想给孩子炖个牛肋条，
想给孩子做点排骨这些，
孩子做点鱼什么的，
这些大肉类也是我买，
比如说我们会每个星期去超市，
比如说家里少了什么青菜，
他就去小区内的超市，
就看孩子随时就买一点，
其实我觉得这事啊，
嗯，
真心话，
我们自己还是小问题，
太自私了一点，
换做是你吧，
因为你一儿一女，
将来你也是当婆婆的，
你又付出劳动了，
一个月就给你，
这刚开始是一千两千，
到现在才长成3000块钱，
这3000块钱你还得花，
买菜，
孩子想吃点啥水果了，
你还。
得买，
换做是你的话，
你怎么想这个问题吧，
你纯付出，
因为我就这么说吧，
我家月儿嫂啊，
她的工资年入是10万打底的，
你还是带俩孩子，
带俩孩子人家10万都不带给你带的，
其实你是在占婆婆的便宜，
是你要想明白这个理儿了之后，
你就发现她甭管说年终奖给了婆婆也好，
一个月给3000也好，
给2000也好，
真的你都是赚的，
我是真心的觉得你是赚的，
因为这俩孩子她毕竟是你的孩子，
毕竟是跟你亲啊，
那婆婆现在是纯付出，
不能跟你细数细说哦，
你要一个月儿嫂，
她要带俩孩子，
工资10万打底，
你还得给她红包哦，
你还得给她买衣服哦，
你还得给她买礼物，
你还得给她情绪价值哦。
所以我直播间的所有的姐妹，
如果婆婆现在帮你带孩子的话，
你真的稍微动动脑筋想一想，
你就知道你是在占婆婆的便宜的，
刚有人说重点是瞒着，
就你这性格，
不瞒着能咋整，
不就被吵架了吗？
我就觉得给婆婆钱我是可以接受的，
但是就是说所有的事情全都是做完以后告诉我，
我心里就很难接受，
我跟你讲啊，
姐妹啊，
我知道我说的这个话出来，
可能大家都会觉得，
龙菲姐，
你是不是对我们当儿媳妇的要求太高了，
不是高，
真正有情商的儿媳妇是根本就别等着这个男的偷偷的给，
一上来就应该要求她给，
上来就应该说，
哎呀，
妈不容易给妈要给点儿子放钱给妈。
给点养老钱，
他带俩孩子在家，
如果他没点私房钱，
没点那个钱的话，
他心里不平衡，
都得你主动提出来，
但是我觉得也没有给我这个机会，
他们家有欠钱这个事情，
包括所有的事情，
我没有说纠结，
我天天跟他吵架，
那样想，
大家该怎样怎么样，
私下我这些情绪自己去消化，
我就觉得为什么要瞒着我呀，
瞒着我就让我觉得挺难受的，
只能说来说去啊，
他也没有偷人，
他也没有说这是他伤天害理的事儿，
他也没干什么出格的事儿，
就这事儿的话，
说到底他也谈不上什么原则性的错误，
我知道我自己的这个纠结实际上就是为了一口气，
我就觉得我，
我为什么要忍着这些事情啊，
为什么你不能先告诉我，
这面上对我很尊重，
但是说这些事情的行为并没有对我很尊重，
我感觉这事儿的话，
你想明白这个道理了，
你想孩子现在多大了，
俩孩子婆婆天天累死累活的哈，
其实是占婆婆便宜了，
所以想生物就过去啊，
是不用西在说，
一直在说给我付钱，
我们不用再这么纠结，
包括出去买衣服，
我也是主动说，
我说需不需要什么是吧，
还要给她买一些营养品之类的，
我也是主动在买，
但是我对我老公这一点我迟迟放不开，
我对我婆婆之间没有什么，
那难道说将来他在外面比如说欠债啊，
或者怎么样也不跟我说说，
哎呀，
告诉你也没有用啊，
告诉你也是我自己还。
再说更深层次的话，
我没有因为情爱而难受，
而是觉得我就是厌不受起。
但我问你，
你的经济上对你的老公是完全公开的吗？
你有没有在经济上你老公不知道的事情呢？
几乎没有，
你赚的每一分钱你老公都知道吗？
我都知道，
因为我是体制内工作，
我们也没有其他收入，
你支出的所有的项目，
你都敢跟老公说吗？
我都敢跟老公说，
不可能，
我觉得不可能，
我不相信，
这真的啊，
我只相信人性，
人性都是自私的，
都有小九九，
你不可能所有的收入，
所有的支出你都愿意跟对方去公开，
我不相信，
因为我做不到，
所以我不相信我给娘家给点什么贴补了，
给娘家哥哥给点什么贴补了，
我不可能一五一十的，
比如说娘家哪个表哥，
那个堂哥，
那个谁就管我借点钱了，
我不可能跟我老公说这个，
首先第1点我家里的人从来没有朝我借过钱，
因为我家里的人其实都不缺钱，
第2点就是贴补娘家这个事情我有，
但是不是说我每年几万块钱贴补，
就比如说哎，
我妈妈说想买一个什么小电器呀，
我看见了我回家买这个事情，
我觉得我没有什么好瞒着我了，
我们就像前段时间我家里买一个热水器吧，
应该是大头儿我妈妈出来因为有什么补贴之类的抖了一下给我出的，
就这个事情我觉得没有什么可瞒着老公。
第二个事儿，
关于我收入，
我收入每年去年子工资花在两个孩子身上是不够的，
所以说每年的这个钱还是需要我老公再给我，
我从他的收入当中花掉一到两万，
才够我们整个小家庭的吃喝拉撒。
去年因为我知道我跟他钱上面就有一点不开心，
所以我就硬挺着没有花他的钱，
现实有点傻，
到年底的时候其实是不够，
我刚才说我不相信一个人可以完全在财务上对另一个人啊，
收入每一笔钱，
支出每一笔钱，
钱花到哪里去了，
都可以完全做到透明，
是因为我做不到，
我真做不到，
所以我就以己度人啊，
或许这个社会上有人能做到吧，
但是如果你能做到的话，
那你是少数人，
你不能以你的这种少数人的标准去要求所有人，
同样的道理，
你能做到说每一笔收入，
每一笔支出都能跟你老公公开，
但你不能要求你老公每一笔收入一笔支出都能跟你公开，
因为人性会有一些东西是阴暗面的，
不想让别人知道，
别说他不想跟你公开，
他都恨不得不想让谁，
全世界都不想让别人查到。
再有一个，
因为毕竟你家里面主要的收入来源还是要靠这个老公嘛，
家里面两个孩子又健健康康的，
婆婆又在帮忙带孩子，
你一旦这个坎儿，
就是经济上这点事儿，
一旦你迈过去了之后，
你日子就好过了，
你老公这经济上这个事儿的话，
基本上可以说。
是常态，
因为现实生活中，
如果说挣钱多的那个人是不可能一笔一笔的，
所有的账都给挣钱少的那个人去汇报清楚的，
这是实话，
我知道你就琢磨明白这个点，
如果有一天把个儿换过来，
你是你们家挣钱多的那一个，
他是那个挣钱少的那个，
你也不可能做到收入的每一笔钱，
支出的每一笔钱都向他去汇报的，
不可能就明白你的意思，
嗯，
就这个意思，
好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜。
我刚刚老看到有人说啊，
龙飞你自从有了个儿子之后，
你现在说话都向着婆婆了，
老说这话有啥意思呢？
啊，
本来就是屁股决定脑袋，
但是你不觉得龙飞不光是会换位思考到婆婆的角度，
我也会换位思考到男人的角度嘛，
我会换位思考到强者的角度，
同时我也会换位思考到弱者的角度，
我没发现这个问题吗？
不是说龙飞一门心思的就帮婆婆说话了，
如果说婆婆那边有什么做的不对的地方，
我是不是也会换位思考到儿媳妇儿的角度，
因为我现在是给人家当儿媳妇儿的，
我将来是给人家当婆婆的，
我在生命当中的话，
我扮演过强者的角色，
我也扮演过弱者的角色，
其实就是换位思考，
刚刚有个朋友说，
说白了就是男方一直防着女方，
把女方当成外人，
女方委屈。
现实生活中，
收入高的防着收入低的难道不是常态吗？
你们自己过日子，
难道你们心里没数吗？
收入高的房着收入低的难道不是常。
开吗？
难道不是正常操作吗？
现实生活中老有那种就自己不挣钱，
老公一年挣100万，
总想管老公那100万，
那怎么可能呢？
用脚指头想想怎么可能呢？
挣100万的人怎么可能给你管他的钱呢？
记得点赞关注哦。